on April seventeenth 2012 film courage
attended the roundtable press interview
for the meg and Lawrence Kasdan film
darling companion this audio contains an
interview with Kevin Kline who plays
Joseph in the film for more information
on darling companion please visit sony
classics calm forward slash darling
companion no his onion same still the
same writer the same director
essentially it's everything is the same
it's just the pace was different that's
all fastenal last year well that's the
whole whole trick to doing independent
film is to keep great pace and momentum
and you're shooting maybe three times as
many scenes in one day as you would on a
big luxurious budget and luxurious
schedule and you try not to sacrifice
quality for that it means they're key it
just means that that first take you
don't learn my lines as we do 40 or 50
takes it'll come no you gotta show up
and be ready to go and things like that
so things are just compressed but
essentially the same I'm touching that
fits that you will work to scale and
took two levers and is there any reason
that you wouldn't wear those loans again
I wouldn't work from for less than scale
or any it's almost if it comes to the
point where we have to pay him to work
for him now draw the line no I said
people I'll options I've done a couple
movies / scale um and it's the only way
to get a lot of these independent movies
made the actors negotiate deals where if
they work they've given just enough
money to to live on during the filming
but then they participate in the in the
back end if the movie suddenly makes
gazillion dollars will participate in
that process we happen to be Lauren's
yet and I'm just assuming the holy
Hollywood studios 1 by relevant to the
superheroes or gimmicks and that he must
have tribes as Jeff first uh I aim to
keep try with this one I don't know the
whole full history but um I mean looking
to the Big Chill to six different
Studios before he found one that said
yes I mean it's hard enough it was hard
enough back then cuz it up car chases
and explosions and he writes about real
people in real situations recognizable
people and studio stone first become
invested less interested in that sort of
story do you think there is about human
beings when we can result in tolerant of
one another that we can love our dogs so
much what's the psychology behind us
well you're not written several books on
the subject I don't nobody better that
is a question that you've known asked
that before but that's I think you had
to record the movie what is that is it
because they're innocent is it because
we're part of their Kingdom we're all
animals we're a different sort of animal
maybe they're they're better than us
they're more loyal they're more pure and
more secure more simple they're not
neurotic they're very few there's some
erotic dog you I I know dogs who are on
antidepressants that's in New York but I
don't know if I'm sure they're off
someone antics presence here two dogs do
have feelings I gather but I mean we
know so little you know there's always
some new study we're oh we found out
that monkeys actually remember kindness
or feel revenge or have certain emotions
that we never thought they would save
dogs say with any other one it's a
mystery but I do think I'm a very
simplistic level two dogs we can project
onto them because they are so innocent
they don't come with a lot of baggage we
speak from experience do you have talked
them I grew up with dollars and I
haven't done we have a dog in my
I just wanted looking a new yoga with me
to have a joke savin you can indeed I
love big dogs its kind of cruel to have
a big dog in new york Oh unless you
really love getting out and running two
or three times a day in the park but we
have a sort of small to medium-sized dog
which is more apartment friendly but is
it about Lawrence that is growing back
again again for thought like the way
rights I like I'm interested in things
he interested in what about human nature
what about relationships looked about
how people will are how they perceive
themselves how they miss perceive
themselves how others perceive them how
just assorted day-to-day struggles of
quote-unquote ordinary people in
ordinary situations as opposed to
extraordinary relic for Lummus people in
extraordinary situation it's so I'm
interested in his writing and I love the
way he directs he's very collaborative
he loved he trusts actors and nothing
makes an actor feel freer and more
inventive and more creative than being
trusted the directors looking at you
like oh god I hope it does this seem
right because i really see it a certain
way it's gotta be jenya they want their
my kind of record is like an arrogance
let's see what you're all going to do
with this material and then if it's
terrible ill he'll bring you back in
line so that's why I keep going back for
more how much you got goes on the
improvisations listen well Larry will
say if you ask him he'll say every every
time an actor opens his mouth and
improvisation even she's saying exactly
the lines that are written considers
improvisation is the animation that
bringing to life that the actor ads it's
his sensibility
mentality it's his taste it's his
technique him it's who he or she is that
will bring his work to life other words
on a page he doesn't eat I it's very
little ad libbing the word here in error
the phrase thrown in that's how it's
always been with his films and that kind
of skirts as hotels and yeah why you
don't usually improvisation is when
there's something missing in the scene
but is so kind of so it's evanescent
done you can't pin it down this church
but things are happening in the writing
and in the playing if you just do it
simply and honestly it doesn't need a
lot we gotta add some more jokes here
you know I guess you fall off the chair
an hour it's sort of you don't have to
dress it up too much and I'm sure you
save on the internet about repeaters in
your research with Kevin need a decline
issue famously fire and mostly I here
mostly from journalist you regret that I
mean any room no um because at the time
I mean there some of them have been
highly successful big moneymakers and
artistically after that brilliantly in
fine no problem I steeler to it at the
time um you know is it because you put
something called Edward says yes well
it's taking it there a number of factors
as far as it go into it pure win among
them laziness as a factor have it just
done something similar to that is a
factor not one to repeat yourself or you
meet the director he just doesn't seem
like a person you want to see first
thing in the morning for three months of
your life
or all day it's a very intense
experience so you want to surround
yourself with actors and directors and
crew members caterers dogs whatever
drivers that are nice people to be
around it's mostly laziness stuff is
this even more important to have an
enjoyable experience on a smaller film
like this when you're moving so quickly
or it is it no I've had highly enjoyable
experiences on big studio films I tend
to have fun when I'm working I have been
fortunate to work with fun people that
it's for whom it is not drudgery and who
are not manipulators and who actually
are collaborators but note the budget it
just means I like moving along it's sort
of theirs it's not a lot of waste is a
lot of sitting around number one waiting
for the lighting you know perfect it's
just just and this the guy who did this
movie for some great party does I name
doesn't take forever but done yeah you
can do 50 takes and you're just using
the first one or two that are but what
they're going to have it with the first
couple somewhere combination of the
first two or three tastes or the 49th
and 50th the rest are just agony in
between because so just doing three or
four takes is fine lies i dunno among an
actor if you have a reputation for being
a very giving and supportive partner and
seeds sighs i got only work right up I
don't understand that there's some I've
heard stories Oh terrible doesn't give
you anything just trouble
not fun to work with I've been spared
that experience did the best actors
community ones who are giving you the
most who were generous emotionally
spiritually professionally their present
there there was the best actress thank
you she was the one exception it's
nothing she's mean-spirited arrogance I
happen I had no hopes for her career
though she was um it was unique she's
this very special person she's unique
she's gifted a lot of fun tremendous fun
to work with we had a ball speaking for
myself if she loads working with me I
she never showed it what we laughed a
lot your characters are kind of
contentious you managing my you must
hide my pleasure very well thank you no
well sort of that I think its peak we
both sort of there's a is a tendency
with actors when you're playing when you
know what your relationship is to the
character when you meet from the day one
when you meet them there's unconsciously
you're starting to form opinions and
make choices about how can i use i don't
like the way this person causes hair i
can use that because i have to dislike
you you're just dumb to be something
that petty and superficial so a lot of
our humor together was a teasing kind
and yes teasing
putting putting each other his or her
place Oh ever even say that money
interesting no I know never that that's
I've worked with actors I dude ever
interesting choice you're making they're
playing playing it as an idiot which is
just bad Jewish there's accurate so I
love it you just had to play him gay
it's very question for King Lear because
I never saw you know position gay okay
those are just that sort of just actor
fun things that we do it's pretty cool
Francis your next project a could well
be it depends it's as a huge cast and
getting everyone in the same place at
the same time and they took them out of
money in place to make the film was I'm
just waiting for a start date the
producer it's actually the same good as
your distal and he's very talented it's
all going to come together shortly so
what were you doing between some
Shakespeare I'm just gonna go about my
business doing yeah whatever their
shakes me this summer briefly come and
do another movie or something in between
depends we I could get a call this
afternoon psyche we're going to start in
two weeks on Franken Francis can you
talk a little bit about your own movie
there's music and I rector you gonna be
singing one of my characters singing
three characters but beyond that just
sounds that sounds interesting mm-hmm so
I don't want to just what you by giving
me any more ante up look like um I'm a
big fan of your bid with mike myers the
phone so if you just about that for my
readers and also love you know what
about a lot everybody clear you just
mentioned it's like you know it could
happen like we need is happening i'm
going to call you're not like that Ray
Lewis and we're all
movie again they come I show up
something robbery Oscar because uh no I
don't know how do you put the Dixon uh
yeah well interesting like that- thing
I've ever got a call it new saying mike
is in makeup to do this character we had
talked about doing it with like six
other actors and it was it was
originally the sketch was that we have
also big movie stars and if at the
Oscars and they're being pulled off
stage and being given lessons by that
guy couldn't get everyone there so long
I am I guess it's not going to happen
and then I get the skulls like my kiss
and make up are you doing anything this
afternoon because he thinks just the two
of you could do it a version of it and
you could just sort of make it up as you
go along if you come down here Nessen
yeah I think that would be fun I never
worked with my buyers so what done we
just kind of wrote it you make it up
then Lulu holding the Oscars ya know how
to hold it yeah David's pigs fun how
good everything is about you that bit of
the way your career is not coming or not
yeah I've come up with movie just gonna
get the novel college no first of all I
mean I what thing I want an Oscar for
was something I never dreamed it had
anything to do with Oscar potential you
know their jokes about Yuri scream oh
god this is just as Oscar envelopes i
get to die i get i get to you save lives
i have to have a rare wasting disease
and yet born so there are certain
trappings that are cliched notions about
what Oscar rules I think I'm past that
now there's no there's no particular
local get an Oscar and no predicting
what won't I mean I think they have
their place in the business but it's not
something I think about I just try to do
things that interest me that might be
part of a movie that I might actually go
see not because I'm in it but just
because the material is how can I lost
autonomy partaking briefly para what
ever lost a family
you can even briefly yes yes we had a
bird that was on my shoulder I forgot he
was on my shoulder and went outside and
flipping the trina he kept calling him
look dumb did you suffer after it no I
found one little look like then no one
will score guys oh I've done that the
girl things yeah that's been remarkable
how similar hey baby very handy that way
yes do you have a favorite one cast in
movie and is it wonder you're in or oh
that's a tricky question ah yeah it said
they're all different they're all fun I
love you to death was pretty crazy fun
just you know working with tracey ullman
everyone in it was just great and the
material was just playing that guy who
is fun as if I had to pick one I like to
do all that but it's up by a length it's
my nose so I keep coming back how are
you good how are you good how are you
off you can see why very like Stewart
work with him yeah yeah he's gone and
he's funny mm-hmm